[Music]
today on what if we're going to build
the highest bridge on planet Earth
welcome to the qinghai Tibet Plateau the
roof of the world it's home to the
world's tallest mountain Mount Everest
but also the longest deepest canyon on
the planet
the yarloom zangbo Grand Canyon
this super Canyon is 505 kilometers long
and six kilometers deep and it's here
that we'll be taking on one of the most
epic engineering Challenges ever
building a bridge so high it could take
your breath away literally
for inspiration let's take a look at how
our project would compare to the world's
current tallest bridge
China's bepanjiang Bridge
this huge concrete cable stage structure
carries people
1341 meters across the baypan river
but even at a dizzying height of 565
meters above the river it would find
itself in a very distant second place
our Bridge would be over 10 times higher
so let's get started
standing face to face with the deepest
canyon in the world you'd be so high
above the rivers below you that you
could stack seven of the world's tallest
skyscraper the Burj Khalifa on top of
each other or the entirety of Mount
Kilimanjaro
but the air you'd be breathing would
have less than half of the oxygen
available at sea level
while working on this gravity-defying
bridge you could suffer from high
altitude illness
this would make breathing difficult
cause headaches and make you feel
light-headed you and your crew should
carry oxygen to be safe if you got dizzy
and fell you'd drop straight through
several different ecosystems
from snowy mountain peaks to temperate
coniferous forests to subtropical
rainforests all in 35 seconds
adding to your already full plate of
design challenges you'd be surrounded by
tall dangerous mountain peaks and your
job would be to connect two of these
mountains
and jayala
they stand a staggering 22 kilometers
apart
this would mean that not only would our
Bridge be ten times higher than the bay
panjang it would also be about 16 times
longer
but just like that one cable stage
suspension would be the best design
option
all you'd need would be massive cables
of tightly braided steel wires they'd
rest on top of towers anchored to either
side of the bridge
a suspension bridge like this would also
be the best way to go because it would
be better at withstanding earthquakes
and the Tibetan Plateau is a region that
is highly prone to earthquakes
but that wouldn't be the only force of
nature you'd have to concern yourself
with you'd also face severe weather
your crew would need to deal with Fog
rain and freezing temperatures
and then there's the wind
Your Design would require the bridge to
be as light and as flexible as possible
but you'd need to make sure it remains
stable even in the most extreme winds
one solution would be to build
pendulum-like devices onto each Tower to
balance any swaying or you could
construct a stabilizer fin beneath the
center of the roadway that would keep
movement to a minimum
but enough about the ways weather could
affect our Bridge what about the ways
our Bridge could affect the weather
all of this Uber engineering would be
underway in a region that's a diverse
habitat for many plants and animals
one of the factors in this is the Steep
v-shape of the canyon it helps funnel
warm moist air North from the Indian
Ocean up to the plateau our Bridge would
need an entire infrastructure to beat
construction demands
your crew would start by building roads
that climb up the mountains and then
working from both sides at the same time
like during the construction of
California's Golden Gate Bridge you'd
bring them together in the center
all of this could definitely impact the
very important flow of air in the region
and you need to make sure that the
construction process doesn't destroy the
habitats of wildlife like the Bangladesh
tiger the bear monkey or the giant boa
constrictor would it be worth it
and is there any way to calculate the
final price tag for a project so huge
and with so many challenges
well given that this is 16 times bigger
than the bay panjing it could cost
upward of two billion dollars at the
very least
but that would be pretty cheap compared
to an even more daring feat of
engineering a highway in space but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]